and it's interesting because Margo
already you are kind of tapping into
that side of the business you're doing a
lot of producing already yeah our our
first feature Antonio will be at
first one yeah that's the the first one
to be released we've actually filmed two
now and we're about to go into we're in
pre-production for our third wow are you
in the mall the first three yes but
after this no oh okay
um I was reading about you and it seems
like the business part of your brain was
developed quite young like you were a
little girl and you were quite business
savvy yes quite Savvy as a kid I would
like steal my brother's toys and sell
them on the side of the road for like an
extortionate
I make up um magic tricks and then make
my family
pay to come see my magic show and then
pay extra if they wanted to know how I
did the trick
that's a really good idea all the time
you would pay extra to find out how they
do that yeah once you get them in I mean
they're already there they already paid
their dollar sure yeah yeah because now
because Ryan you were also a young
entrepreneur weren't you
I wouldn't say that no
well didn't your father what did he eat
he wanted you to sell was it sell if
anyone to do so
my parents Came Upon a truck of
cellophane somehow
it's not to ask too many questions
I just suddenly there was a basement
filled with cellophane and uh
they encouraged me to go to school and
see if I could sell it to my teachers or
put a few in my backpack and try and
hock them at recess you know
convince kids that they might be a good
stocking stuffers for their parents
cellophane
how did it go
what do you mean what's the use of
silver I know the name but I don't know
what you do with it you know your wrap
sandwiches in it it keeps things fresh
oh okay
I'm sorry no no no it was an important
question you needed to ask it yeah
I'm not doing a good job of selling it
obviously but did you did you sell it
there's still some left if you're
interested
it would be nice to someone the dream
was someone would just say I'll take all
of it
it never happened
it's a weird story
it is a bit weird now you tell it yes
Timothy chalamet before this hadn't you
oh God I had met him about a year
previous we were doing the the kind of
award season rounds together and I loved
his surname chalamet and I every time I
read it I read it as shalomala bing bong
and when I saw him at this event someone
was coming to introduce me and I said in
my head I was like Timothy Bing Bong as
I was walking towards him to the point
where it's now become such a name in my
family that my gran met him last week at
however many weeks ago
and after she came up she's like I met
Timothy
what's his name now in our family so
Timothy Bing Bong but also uh Meryl's
Street yeah I mean your share like you
have scenes with the real street I
shared space with her no we shared a
carriage for a whole day and a room for
a whole day it was and as Greta Gerber
does she give you a little pep talk
beforehand gonna you're going to be in a
carriage Street you know does anyone
prepare you for it no you kind of just
know that she's she's in the room or
she's somewhere in the house
um because everybody's on best behavior
and everybody likes really quickly and
everybody sets up cameras very quickly
because Meryl's around so you always can
tell that she's somewhere didn't you say
that when you were doing an outside
scene like she has this power she speaks
and things happen
we were in a carriage for a long time
and it takes a while to reset shots
because we were in horse we were behind
horses and it took about 20 minutes each
time and it was cold and we were in
Boston and Timmy came up and kind of
jumped up on the carriage and just as he
jumped up on the carriage a waft of uh
chip smell came in and she suddenly then
wanted chips and within about I'd say 10
minutes there was a gasping PA like
so I sat in in a carriage dripping in my
fine clothes
um eating Wendy's fries
photographic evidence
[Applause]
you do have a connection I've got a
weird intro to show business via was it
your uncle I believe yeah that's right
so he
so was your uncle living with you yes
and did you walk into the room once I I
walked into the room once and he was
um
bedazzling a a sequined white jumpsuit
and and he said that he was going to be
Elvis for a little while
and and and you know would I like to
help and uh he said absolutely what do
you need me to do so I became his head
of security
and he got my whole family in on the ACT
my mother was a backup singer and um
honestly it was one of the greatest
performances I've ever seen
I mean it was it was really affecting no
no he yeah he I mean what I admired
about what he was doing was that he
looked nothing like Elvis you know he
didn't attempt too he had a mustache and
very little hair and
um but my God he just he just became him
and uh you know he would end every show
with uh Suspicious Minds
and he would get on his knees and and
often with tears in his eyes he would he
would sing to some imaginary woman and
beg her not to leave and we were
transported from this mall in my small
town in
Ontario to to to that I imagine it was a
kitchen and she was trying to leave and
we were just in that moment every night
and it was
it was incredible and and honestly one
of the best like
acting lessons I've ever ever had yeah I
wish I could have helped out with those
sequins
I would have liked that how old were you
when you were doing security
I want to say six
it's quite quiet
I had two tiny guns
okay so there's no photo
no uh I painted a picture yeah
no photo this is very I love how kind of
California this is you you swim with
dolphins no well I've taken up the hobby
of scuba diving which I really really
enjoy
um and so we went down I've been shark
diving which is kind of amazing although
I had a real close encounter with a
shark
it wasn't it was about six feet so we
didn't eat people
it wasn't but it wasn't trying to
diminish myself just the type of fish
fish
[Music]
[Applause]
I love you I'm one of you I'm here for
you
I'm going to just [__] on all of your
stories but I think of rules for
swimming with dolphins with dolphins I
heard that you're not supposed to touch
a dolphin unless they come to you and
offer themselves for a rubber oh
you're not supposed to touch them if
they don't because dolphins mate for
life and if you touch one of them the
other one can smell your you'll touch on
them and they think that they've cheated
on them and then that you can break up a
dolphin marriage that is true that is
fact I know I'm gonna have to grown up
Sea World directly
in that one's blower
she's had a dolphin orgy if that's the
case yeah I mean I reckon I've broken up
a few dolphin marriages
um I went to Cuba and I sort of was in a
situation where they were like do you
want to swim with dolphins and they
actually taught me how to
sort of be lifted up on the nose of two
dolphins with their foot on each on
these now if you think she's making it
off somebody filmed it that's a good
story we've got the footage not oh I was
near a fish once
oh
[Applause]
Emily have you got any footage of you
near that fish
there's more of you a goth I yes I
definitely had my I don't know if I was
full goth very emo though okay uh and I
listened to like only heavy metal music
and I would dye my hair black and only
cut it with a razor blade
does anyone like heavy metal music was
that was that something you genuinely
like I genuinely and I still genuinely
like it yeah do you like monster trucks
and things like that no
no it's the whole kind of thing yeah no
just no I really like it like I remember
yeah I'd go to con I I remember going to
the Slipknot concert and the most I've
ever been at the time I was on neighbors
I have never had more people come up to
me ever than out of Slipknot concert
they cute the crossover between it
wasn't monster trucks and Slipknot it
was neighbors
the summary ever kept coming up and
being like it's quite the Venn diagram
they're worried about all the characters
and there's someone says baby okay
they're not real yeah no I know they
were so invested in neighbors and
Slipknot so I I don't know yeah no I
genuinely like that that because so it's
family listening it's yeah now Matt
Damon have you ever been in a musical
yeah is this a musical no
no but I'm playing Humpty Dumpty in that
thing
but look at the dedication you're taking
it really seriously that was I was full
on I I mean I was I don't know 14 or
whatever but I knew this is what I
wanted to do and I thought it took that
kind of determination
so I was not at school is this when you
because you went to school with Ben
Affleck yes yeah and that's when your
connection started was back then yeah
yeah but even at that age you as you
said you both took it very seriously
yeah we've talked about how weird it is
that I mean no one in our families was
in the the industry I mean we lived in
Boston or Cambridge Massachusetts not a
town that had you know I mean it was it
was very odd that we both wanted to do
this and we lived just two short blocks
away from each other and and uh had this
each had this kind of singular kind of
individual passion for this thing and so
when we met it kind of reinforced
you know everything for both of us and
and that was kind of how our friendship
started and this is when you you would
have the lunches these acting lunches
business lunches yeah we call them
business lunches and you were like 14
yes I was 16 and he was 14 and and we
would and we would there were two
cafeterias we went to a very big high
school there were three thousand kids
and uh there was the main cafeteria and
then what they called the media
cafeteria which was a small cafeteria
and we would meet at the media cafeteria
yes for a business lunch
it would be like hey man business lunch
today yeah yeah I'll see you there 12
30. and then we get there and we get our
cheeseburgers and we sit down and we
wouldn't have anything to talk about we
didn't know so what's going on you know
but it was during that time that we
would go to New York together and uh and
audition for um you know we got an agent
and we started traveling to New York and
then eventually mercifully not right
away but after a few years started
getting some work and yourself and Ben
Affleck the the night of the winning
Orchestra because we I think we just saw
a picture there you are because how old
were you there
uh I'm 27 and Ben's 25. well you look
even younger yeah yeah yeah but you know
funnily enough we'd been in the business
for a while then I mean we'd been I got
in the union when I was 16. so I mean
that's 11 years after getting in the
union but that still must be such a kind
of mind
thing yeah I mean it's still it took a
really long time to to just process
everything I mean things happen so fast
you know even though we'd been hanging
around Hollywood for a long time it and
and that and that
movie Good Will Hunting you know was
five years in the making so it it it it
it happened kind of in slow motion for
us we were anxious to get it going
things weren't moving fast enough but
once all of that happened that happened
kind of over that that night must have
sent you into a tailspin do you go crazy
that that actual night did you go nuts
actually I remember I remember very
clearly going back with my girlfriend at
the time and we went to the uh her house
and she went to sleep and
and I seriously I couldn't well
I had a ponytail back then
so
but but I but I couldn't sleep I I was
just kind of still buzzing it and was
sitting there and I remember very
clearly looking at that award and
um and and thinking very very clearly am
I allowed to say a four-letter word on
this show I literally looked at it I was
alone with it and I said to myself thank
God I didn't [__] anybody over for this
and I suddenly had this kind of thing
wash over me where I thought imagine
chasing that and not getting it
and getting it finally in your 80s or
your 90s with all of life behind you and
realizing what an unbelievable waste of
your you know what I mean because it
can't it's got to be you know what I
mean it's not it it can't be good enough
right it can't fill you up it will never
if that's a hole that you have that
won't fill it right and and I felt so
like blessed to have that
and because I I wouldn't have known it
unless I I knew it you know and you're
right like imagine figuring out at 80
that'd be how and I literally like my
heart broke for a second I I it's like I
imagined another one of me you know an
old man kind of going like oh my God
where did my life go what did what have
I done and then it's over you know we're
going to focus on the early dancing
career of Mr Ryan Gosling
um
so the dance troupe you were in can you
tell us about because apparently young
dancers they could be quite vicious
it's a Cutthroat business
had to get out
I I was on some kind of uh Canadian Star
Search and uh I somehow made it to the
finals and uh my main competition were
these two uh twins who were tap dancers
and they were dancing to Phil Collins uh
two hearts oh
cool and they had big heart-shaped bows
and they were just uh they were the ones
to beat so
I remember uh you know wishing them luck
and going on stage and I was getting
ready to start was dancing the Everybody
Dance Now by CNC Music Factory of course
yeah and I'm getting ready to start
which is this is how you started a
winning dance number if you want to know
into the uh just off stage and the two
twins are standing there like the twins
from The Shining
and they're just going like this laughs
[Applause]
I was like all right that means war is
like I just shimmied my way all the way
to to that trophy to that tiny little
trophy
came through I was going to say it's an
old it's an old girl true but obviously
it's not you're in it right but but
you are the only boy in it yeah that was
the it was that the that was the point
that was the gimmick they let me dance
there for free because I was a guy
because if you had a guy you you would
win oh okay yeah so are you ready to see
the the advanced silence I believe your
dad's saying to Kathy Dennis's classic
touch me
um to the troop of a name Ryan
it was Elite Dance Studio
how old are you
old enough to know better
enjoy
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I wish I could say someone said here you
have to wear this
well that was my idea I thought I have a
vision for this number
Silver Hammer pants they are the Silver
Hammer pants are I don't think we gave
them enough of a shot we gave up with
hammer but I think we should we should
have kept them going we didn't get no
yeah they make up
your home life animals is it a farm you
have we yeah we wound up inheriting what
was an old dog and horse rescue oh I see
up there in Malibu way and then uh there
was all these empty stables and I I
can't stand negative space
plus I'm a softy at heart and there's a
lot of rescue uh so these old rescues
largely so we've got some llamas yes
where there's uh Madre and that is fuzzy
on the left
they were rescued from I needed sweaters
he's gone too short myself
the alpha don't mess with her and then
you've got these lovely cows we do those
are Oreo cows I saw some in Richmond and
then they said they had them up in Santa
Barbara I said give us a couple belted
galloways I believe they're called thank
you you're welcome
there you go
ladies and gentlemen How Excellent
I should corrected belted galloways Oreo
cows is cute is better yeah that's how
you learn yeah that's an Oreo cow but
then you've got some very ordinary
things you've got some chickens knocking
around yes that's a Bert up front
you don't know the names no chickens
okay then now goats I feel are hard to
keep these yes that looks like that's a
trigger in memo they are pygmy goats and
they are also brother lovers oh yeah oh
very modern it's perfect yeah do these
come in the house uh not when they're
active okay
is this trigger a memo this one oh my
God that is our newest one and and his
sweet name is Flash
and uh that's a real he's a real rescue
uh he looks like he's possessed by the
devil
and then you have one of the most
relaxed cats I've ever seen
oh that's Montgomery named after your
great General that's amazing he's sort
of more of an ointment really
yeah
the cat has melted yeah she's heavily
sedated there
Marco I I don't know if you were a
terrible child but do you know the story
I'm talking about where like you do not
win any awards for being a good daughter
there are many stories where I don't win
I was not a great dude I I am forever in
my mum's debt because I was such a brat
and I feel really bad about it tell us a
story about when you were on your
computer and she wanted your help oh yes
she yes okay so I um I was on MSN uh
obviously the most important thing at
the time
and uh we moved out like you know out in
the sticks and often snakes would get
into the house and um you know it wasn't
a big deal but you just have to like
chase them around and get it out and
it's kind of time consuming and annoying
and so my mom yelled out and she was
like can you come help me there's this
snake's really big like I can't get it
on my own can you come help me and I was
like
so busy mum no I can't like just being a
brat because I was on MSN and she was
like oh I just okay I should please and
I was like big on and um and then she
was she was gone for like 10 minutes and
I was like
oh she's been gone for ages and then I I
like got up from the computer I could
hear like this
and I was like oh God what's happening
and I see mum she's like made it halfway
down the stairs and the snake she tried
to like pick this big python up with her
but with a broom and a stick but it had
wound its way up around her arm and was
going around her neck
no I know I'm painting a bad picture
it's really not bad but um
it wasn't poisonous steak but they do
they do they do strangle you yeah
you just got to give it something else
to climb on so you get a stick or
something it starts weaving its way
around that and then you can transfer
its weight and good to know get it off
yeah
just you grab it behind its head you
grab it behind us
you just don't want it to bite you
mother okay yeah she was fine I felt bad
and I tried not to be such a brat when
Mom asked for help in future I kind of
did it a lesson a lesson learned very
good you shout yourself well yeah I mean
I mean I mean
Emily I'm coming around to you
yeah
most delicious street food things I ever
ate made me ill and but it was delicious
made me ill how ill very ill the idea on
the loo for weeks oh wow it was it was a
pigeon past year in in Marrakech I mean
it sounds like a recipe for if you don't
mind me saying diarrhea yes in the
interest of balance I shot myself on a
bus in Turkey
blood
line
I wish I had a Merry Christmas Story
I've never [__] my pants guys I'm sorry
well Steve Michaels this evening are
called Emily Blunt Mary pooping
very good
now could you not afford toilet paper or
you just didn't feel that was a good
thing to spend money on
as you use what did you use instead no
no no it's not that all right what did
you use instead
I could have bought it I mean it wasn't
you know I wasn't flush at the time
but I was also working all the time and
I was busy I know exactly what you're
referring to I know exactly what picture
you're referring to because it's the
first time I got packed and it was
really embarrassing I'd just been my
friend was in New York in town she was
going back to Australia and she was like
oh look I've got some like there's still
do you want the rest of that my makeup
or whatever I'm not gonna pack it I was
like no no I'm good I was like oh I've
got no toilet paper at home though and I
haven't had time to stop and I was like
what's going on I'll took the toilet
paper because I didn't have time to go
to the shops
um otherwise I would is the financial
thing and I took her bag which was a
Ralph Lauren bag but I didn't realize at
the time and when I walked out of the
building suddenly like all these cameras
like and I was like oh my God someone
famous was around I was like who is it
and then my cousin's like I think
they're taking photos of you I was like
oh God this is the worst time to get
photographed I've just got stolen toilet
paper I got that picture and it is
genius knowing that in the bag is just a
lot of stolen toilet paper
first day was that iconic possibly I
mean voted maybe one of the greatest
performances of all time yeah and then
we shot that on day one wow yeah I think
it was kind of a baptism by fire but it
was it was a sink or swim moment where I
thought okay this is just a test so if I
can't do this I'm out of here
but the transformation is extraordinary
in here and a bit like keeping the
accent up all the time you did you keep
the teeth in all the time yeah I had his
teeth in because he has a over by a
massive over by which he never wanted to
mess with because he has four octave
range that he said I'm not screwing with
this at all so I had these teeth made
I'm I was like you I enjoyed it so much
I'm not a method Act I'm a method actor
so let's stop talking down method X
no problem with that I'm just saying I'm
not I'm right
I've worked with I've worked with method
actors that I absolutely adore and we
can go on about that I'll tell you about
this yeah
I cut my teeth in because I never get a
chance to end every sentence with
darling and dear and Freddie does and
that's quite nice it's nice it's nice
being I'd rather be Freddie Mercury for
most of the day than be around me
appreciate it and uh being an astronaut
preparing to go to space presumably you
have to
prepare to be an astronaut to go to
space so you are to do all this stuff in
the film like that weird whirly geek
thing yeah multi-access trainer that
looks horrible yeah I don't remember
much
I just remember the director saying more
spinning
then the rest is kind of a blank because
are you just in it or do you control it
in some way no you don't control it or
can you just hit it yeah yeah feeling
and did you get sick a lot
wow
no it was very hard to complain because
at any the director went through such uh
lengths to make sure this was authentic
I mean incredible amount of detail into
making these capsules uh
um you know almost exactly as they were
and we had uh you know technicians who
were involved in these missions on set
every day and any time you thought about
complaining you know you would go to the
Monitor and somebody you know some
astronaut would say well you know Ryan
when I went to the moon
and then he just keeps talking and you
slowly forget about what it was that was
bothering you yeah that's right
but you decided you were going to learn
how to fly because you know I'm talking
about planes that's right yeah how did
that go you know I knew uh Neil Neil
could fly before he he could drive he he
grew up washing planes as a kid so he
could pay for lessons and flight was
just you know so important to him so I
thought I'll learn how to fly and you
know you always hear about celebrities
flying and I was like how hard could it
be
well it's very hard
it's very hard and uh
pretty quickly into my training my my
flight instructor told me to take the
plane into a self-imposed stall
just you stall it on purpose and I just
thought this is a terrible idea I'm
gonna land right away and I'll spend my
time learning other things
you're English but you had a dialect
coach for the English accent I did yeah
because I've lived in America for so
long that that um I live in California
and and I just my kids are American and
um I just that's the set that's what I
hear around me all day so I have little
things that I don't notice that sort of
slip in so I I had a voice coach to I
had to brush up my English
wow yeah well you'd be Smiley and then
suddenly you'd hit like a hard r or
something or a weird sound would would
come out so uh I needed to sort of have
English lessons
who's in Robocop she was saying
introduce you to a very good Australian
accent
um
now I'm on the spot with someone
well I don't know there's that sort of
that's slight there's that sort of
subtle uh kind of accent that's that
just sort of touches the words
um
having not started and then this course
you know like the the full-on you know
possible absolutely
we're not here to [__] spiders
truck
you were out and about you did the
traditional uh pouring the pint of
Guinness well we were shooting at this
uh Pub and and they asked me to pour a
pint of Guinness and I thought this is
going to be amazing and I'm gonna crush
it didn't at all so there was a crowd of
people who were actually in the pub I
think our movie was very tiny so there
was no sort of locking down of sets we
were just there you know people were
there
and so there's a crowd of people
watching before the party who were very
uproarious at first they were just like
cheering and then as the Pint just
turned into a pint of foam it just it
just kind of dwindled to nothing I think
we've got a picture of the paint yeah
that is sacrilege and also there's a
great I'm gonna beg up there's an
Instagram account called [__] London
Guinness
[Laughter]
I don't know some some Legend I think
he's from Cork or something and I
basically people put send them in these
awful notoriously terrible Guinness here
in London and um you know it's like no
head at all loads of hair sometimes
against uh trying to get us in a like a
Heineken glass like some Dreadful
sacrilege but that would be straight on
there yeah
even Christopher Walken was like that's
bad
that's so wrong
right I think it's the angle yes maybe
so much gas in the pipe too much gas
pipe just like Jamie Dornan
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it worked right it was funny yeah it was
funny that was funny everyone on the
couch uh when you've been towards shows
the Oscars you've all taken your parents
which is I mean that seems you know to
have four of you all do this
lovely is that now Ryan your mom she I
mean I'm sure she likes meeting the
celebrities but isn't it the gift room
is really her thing she enjoys
I don't want to out my mom like this
I will tell a funny story about that
picture though which is that my Mom was
convinced that year by her friend that
beehives were going to be all the rage
and if you didn't have a beehive you'd
feel embarrassed and it turned out to be
the opposite it was a natural hair vibe
that
and my mom sat in front of uh Rachel
wise and her hair was so high that
Rachel had to keep
sinking in her chair and I didn't know
what to do because I was you know I
wanted to have a nice night so I I
didn't know Meryl Streep but she was
sitting next to me and I said in a
commercial break would you would you
mind just telling my mom you like her
hair you know and she was like I got
this and then the commercial when she
goes do you know I wish I was going to
do a beehive and I wish I had
I was like
did she already know that story your mom
my mom yeah
you're having a special New Year's Eve
because you like someone on the couch oh
oh I know I do I mean I like all of you
on the couch
like one more than the other
no I I particularly love the sound of
Tom Hank's voice oh my really yeah
that's great
no my mom actually reminded me this
morning she found out that you were here
and um she said do you remember because
I was sick quite a lot as a kid and I
was always in hospital and they were
always trying to find a good position
for me to sleep in and um apparently I
would always wake up when Toy Story was
over and the ending credits would play
so she'd quickly get up from her bed and
Rewind it and press play again so I'm
I've been very soon sleep you got a
friend
[Applause]
because you've spent a lot of time here
how long did you live here for you've
just I only just moved begrudgingly
moved because we opened our production
office in LA but I was living here for
the last
three years okay and I don't know why
I'd be surprised because you're a Margot
Robbie living in London so of course you
did but you did mix in some highfalutin
circles yes oh yes I don't know where
this picture came from oh okay well
that's obviously you is that is that
Sienna Miller yeah I think so and that's
a princess is it a Beatrice one or a
Eugenie one
I can't tell by the picture everyone
kind of looks weird you're you're
picking everyone better than I can uh I
think it's one of them
um tell us who this is
you know I know it's Prince Harry I
don't normally go to party people are
there that was a one-off okay that
doesn't normally happen my my friends
aren't Royals
but anyway they're of course is Cara
delevina is a good friend of mine yeah
you were a Suicide Squad together yeah
yeah she's she's awesome and I'm in uh
The Suicide Squad you tattooed your cast
members is this right yes because you're
kind of you're trained so these are the
tattoos you do yeah we call them Tomo
juice okay and you do them all the cast
no weirdly enough no one else wanted
them um
so just the two of us got the toe emojis
but everyone else got Squad written on
them and other people just would come by
the trailer and get anything and yeah so
I did all sorts of things and you so you
can still touch two people yeah I reckon
I've done yeah
probably like getting close to 100 now
little ones little ones and honestly I'm
probably getting worse as I go along
because we have a tattoo gun here oh boy
so if anything
if any of you down
if any of your coachmates want a tattoo
oh do you to commemorate this lovely
all right
the kids are here
you pierced your ear uh yeah not myself
um oh it would be so funny please
that's everything you get might but I
I'm seeing you actually are prepared oh
yeah I have this stuff yeah no no she
can tattoo this isn't actually my gun
but I could I can make do with it for
sure
are you genuinely thinking about this no
you are not at all that's acting
[Applause]
so shocked because you've already
tattooed yourself haven't you
yeah
go for you not great
uh it was uh you know it was supposed to
be a you know like the class like a
Monster Hand dropping a bloody heart
but it it looks more like a
like a chicken you know making love with
a cactus or something
I don't know what happened
a friend had one at his house I like to
doodle It's a bad combination
works on our team and they are a big
Margot Robbie fan and they I would I say
they're willing to do this I mean
they're very keen uh he's washed his
feet tout them so what is it I mean is
it difficult to do this Emoji thing no
I'll be fine yeah so Adam your moment is
here this is happening okay
[Applause]
my own production team but you could
have taken your shoes and socks off
first it would have saved a little time
you knew this moment was coming I wanted
it to be more real okay okay here we go
here we go you don't have to do this if
you don't want to honestly
kept saying that he wants to do this
okay
are you sure yeah okay
oh I know there's something I have to
say now this is legally uh don't try
this at home
okay perfect okay here we go okay okay
in your own time that will
it's not that easy no no okay here we go
here we go I actually haven't done one
for a while
I'm sorry I'm probably more nervous than
you are to be honest sorry that's not
comforting I'm not gonna say that that
wasn't very professional
I'm so scared I'm gonna say my hands are
shaking but you don't want to hear that
[Applause]
okay
sorry
um
does it hurt it's a little little funny
yeah don't worry about your finest work
you do seem happy in your work I really
do I'm not particularly good but I like
doing it
thank you
[Applause]
this poker face had a very good
sorry is that all right just good yeah
okay
neaten it up like when we're off like
backstage or something yeah
there it is
that's not bad it's not bad
[Music]
all right